as usual so it's magnus with the white
pieces against anish giri anish as we
know one of the best if not the best
played
best prepared players
in
the world
and magnus
does not choose a sideline but he goes
for the catalan which he also played
in the match i think he once played the
pure catalan and then he once played d4
another six and a half three d5 g3
so he's been dabbling with it he was
played against jesse panko and the world
cup last year
and anish goes bishop e7
but oh no i can actually
once again very freely
pled ignorance i don't know anything
about knight a3 i know stuff about queen
c2 which probably isn't very surprising
this was played in the match
and i know some things about knight e5
not necessarily from the match but
knight a3 i know very little i know that
you're supposed to take it
and now go bishop d7 i played knight c6
once again with roman nishin but it's
supposed to be less good
so i think bishop d7 and then knight e5
bishop c6 is supposed to be fine for
black
a4 that's the position yeah but just
blisses about a4 and uh
yeah this is quite confusing and uh
well the immediate temptation here is to
say that you know he probably should
hang around dub of a bit less because
how are winning the spawn back after
bishop c6 so i take on g2 and go knight
c6 i suppose
looks perfectly fine for black to me
yeah
i mean we're probably not better but i
don't know 495 takes take everything
maybe this is a line i don't know
but rook c4 hang on we can grab into
five check wins material right so yeah
quincy by the speed and it might not
have been surprised by this
a4 move which i think is meant as a
surprise 95 is what you usually do here
as far as i know you play queen c2
what now
then one and e4 yeah
whichever rook i don't know which one is
stronger but i'm guessing rookie one you
know you know you can't explain even
after talking it out for five minutes
it is potentially something that might
be very interesting and you might learn
something
but so far yeah i don't quite know what
what is the intention here
why would you do that
it was hot it was extremely hot
but yeah white sneakers then people
don't have to take their shoes off
anywhere anymore
yeah rook ac one played by magnus is
still obviously playing a tempo he he
knows this stuff
this might not even be a gambit right
because you're kind of running out of
moves a little bit with black useful
moves that is saying bishop d5 never
makes sense because you're going to have
one yeah it's coming
yeah it's a bit it's a bit strong but i
probably didn't miss queen takes c4 but
usually if people say blunder it means
he didn't play the first computer move
yeah that normally is the explanation
yeah
and yeah it did take a lot of time a6
plate i guess threatening b5 magnus took
knight b6 similar to what we talked
about with the pawn on
a5 it's once again queen c2 or maybe the
suspicion has to be its quincy two
specifically right
looks psychological yeah bishop a4 queen
c7 has to be pretty unpleasant
unless we can catch that rogue but we
probably cannot right take stakes hang
on a second can we
take stakes and we go when queen c3
saying please take with the knight i'll
even give you a tempo
or please move this knight yeah this is
an interesting choice yeah
definitely better in case of bishop
takes a four but yeah there are so many
additional options now
knight e4 we genuinely don't like very
much though right because of them
after queen c2 you might be in trouble
because knight is looks like the most
natural but then after knight b6 what's
the big move yeah we're we're kind of
basically what this is taking
i don't believe in the exchange
sacrifice and without the exchange
sacrifice i'm not quite sure where we're
getting here
yeah i think going to be three plates
on the subject of options for black is
queen d5 playable here
okay
or does that lose some material to
either rook c6 one knight somewhere no i
don't quite see like 95 q5 right i don't
actually lose material do i
talking about
he probably didn't like that position
very much there's really
one explanation for not playing 96 there
i think
and that is the exchange stack
so our current thinking here is knight
h4 right
i like it better than knight t1 i think
keeping the rooks connected feels
useful we have action in the cards in
theory game so let's jump straight to
that
peter we left it after queen d5 and we
had already figured out with the help
of the chat
and
some engines
that rook takes c6 queen c6 95 queen v5
queen c2 was interesting and that is
indeed on the board so magnus sacrifices
an exchange in the pawn
but has some threats now
yeah
it seems like it might be a
might be a temporary sacrifice i can't
figure out a way for black to to keep
the material yeah looks like anish might
have gotten lost in this briar patch
here
and went
knight to d5 which
is not approved right yeah apparently
bishop before he's very strong yeah i
guess queen a5 and then queen c3 against
anything right
well by anything i mean knight c4
specifically
i'm sure you can find moves against
which i will not want to play queen c3
but
rugby one played
um
it looks first
yeah 25 will be
will be the reply
yeah and this will be 508. well we'll
find out in a moment because magnus
magnus played bishop d5
completely wrong he played ed
why was it completely wrong just rook p7
it's rugby 7 and we just don't see any
defense against the combined threats
and he might be back to being completely
lost right queen of five i assume or
anything honestly
it looks like this [ __ ] should just be
made right it just doesn't seem like a
defensible position with all the
pieces why it has an attack
uh
queenie one checking g2 doesn't really
add
very much to your options either
three we can take yeah we can just take
i don't think this does very much yeah
computer says something like minus 0 10
which maybe is the price to pay for
getting position but let's have a look
at what happens now
he played c5 yeah i think he just gets
on the board
and according to peter's little queen of
five checkmates here even though 95
drops the variation by four pawns it's
different they're missing
yeah g i mean like
c6 or g3 takes e3 is also like
just sort of inexcusable
let's play 28 in the meantime
yeah
just dc here we've
uh i think we've discussed this right dc
kind of forces you to play this is the
line
oh this is just completely winning is
this this is fairly over right yeah c7
and just get the knight to d6 and
27 yeah whatever
yeah this is yeah but king h8 you
probably have to go back
seems somewhat pointless
yeah this i think this is very strong
but a completely unplayable once again
because dc5 is just so obviously winning
so why would you ever do that and he has
played dc fine
the one thing you have to realize here i
guess i mean like the one variation you
have to count is
something like queen eight queen takes
d5
and once you realize this is completely
winning you no longer really have to
count hang on knight c3 though
is it completely winning
hmm a spoiled checkmate
check
it doesn't work unfortunately because
you can take yeah that was very happy i
actually found a way to improve on that
but i don't know if it worked like i
wanted to suggest not queen d5
provoking without the check queen of
five knights
three and now
and bishop b2
c3 there's a bishop on b2
but shades of this position are on the
board we should b2 d4
yeah i think chad was suggesting bishop
b7 was even stronger for some reason i
don't quite understand why but
also here it's not about winning quickly
but about winning surely which probably
magnus will have yeah yeah yeah just
anyway and it's resigned yeah
no point continuing yeah i i think i
think the opening is actually
interesting enough to
make it a possibility because i think
both more terms invite as well have sort
of become a rarity
it's not like they never happen but they
happen much
much less often
than they used to but this was a fun
enough game until it suddenly wasn't
to perhaps married to analysis
because i i honestly i don't think
magnus knew
very much
about the position after i think he
actually worked out much of it over the
board
from the timings my suspicion is he
perhaps was surprised by a6 and had to
think from there on
um and then you know because obviously
if if like everything after rook takes
e6 and quincy 2 and and and the rest of
it
is just in his files there's he'll just
tell any shafter afterwards and there's
not much point to
to discuss it
but if if they both had to think of what
are files
what
um yeah no i i agree with everything
that's good
just